las autoridades chilenas trabajan en ese
mismo momento para tratar de controlar
los focos activos del incendio de viña
del mar que podrían ser reactivados con
las condiciones climáticas que se
esperan para esta tarde de fuertes
vientos el presidente Gabriel borich
está siendo desplazado a la zona del
incendio que ocurrió en la tarde del
jueves a última hora de la tarde
alrededor de las 7 chilenas en la parte
alta de la ciudad balneario de viña del
mar y se extendió rápidamente a
asentamientos irregulares y todas las
quebradas en la parte superior para
llegar incluso a amenazar al palacio de
la quinta Vergara donde tradicionalmente
se celebra el famoso ves festival de
viña de mar de la canción finalmente el
fuego fue atajado antes de que llegara
allí las condiciones climáticas pudieron
llevar el fuego en otra dirección y
llegar a afectar mucho más de lo que en
realidad ocurrió pero no obstante viña
del mar se levantaba en la mañana de
este viernes completamente desolada por
las de destrucción del incendio que fue
voraz y que acabó con 130 viviendas
completamente destruidas se evalúan
daños que estiman que las viviendas
afectadas podrían ser entre 200 y 500
dos personas fallecidas y 30 lesionados
empieza a desplegar la ayuda por parte
de la comunidad chilena por parte de las
regiones aledañas para enviar alimentos
y también agua pañales y otros enseres a
estas personas afectadas por la falta de
vivienda en estos días a pocos días de
la Navidad